[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing harry potter the prisoner of
azkaban dementors and tom riddle more
specifically we're going to be
discussing a recurring event in the
prison of azkaban harry's encounters
with dementors and the shocking truth
behind what harry hears during these
attacks
i'm also going to be discussing a theory
for why dementors seem to be so drawn to
harry are his numerous run-ins with
dementors the result of sheer dumb
misfortune or were they drawn to him for
another more sinister reason dementors
are of course the prison guards of
azkaban giant dark cloak creatures three
meters tall with dark gray scabby skin
and if they don't sound awful enough
already it turns out they're also
representative of depression dementors
are among the foulest creatures that
walk this earth they infest the darkest
filthiest places they glory and decay
and despair they drain peace hope and
happiness out of the air around them
even muggles feel their presence though
they can't see them get too near a
dementor and every good feeling every
happy memory will be sucked out of you
if it can the dementor will feed on you
long enough to reduce you to something
like itself
soulless and evil you'll be left with
nothing the worst experiences of your
life one of the recurring moments
throughout the third book movie is the
appearance of dementors and a
particularly chilling effect they have
on harry potter himself every time harry
is confronted with a dementor he hears
the screams of his mother as she is
murdered by lord voldemort this first
occurs right in the beginning of the
prisoner of azkaban an intense cold
swept over them all harry felt his own
breath catch in his chest the cold went
deeper than his skin it was inside his
chest it was inside his very heart
harry's eyes rolled up into his head he
couldn't see he was drowning in cold
there was a rushing in his ears as
though of water he was being dragged
downward the roaring growing louder and
then from far away he heard screaming
terrible terrified pleading screams he
wanted to help whoever it was he tried
to move his arms but couldn't a thick
white fog was swirling around him inside
him harry recalls one of his attacks
when they get near me i can hear
voldemort murdering my mum
now let me start off by saying that it's
pretty much the general consensus that
the scream harry hears while on the
train back to hogwarts and the prisoner
of azkaban belongs to his mother lily
why is she screaming well she's
screaming because voldemort is in her
family's home and she is pleading with
him to spare harry's life to take her
instead the reason for this assumption
is because when one encounters a
dementor they're forced to relive and
they felt during the worst memory of
their lives logically in harry's case
this would be the murder of his mother
which he was conscious for albeit a baby
but what i want to do today is challenge
this notion and this quote from harry
battling a dementor fighting for his
soul is certainly no pleasant or easy
experience to deal with which is why i
think that harry may have things upside
down
in the disorientating experience that is
a dementor attack i'm of the impression
that what harry heard wasn't actually
his memory at all but rather voldemort's
let me explain it all started the night
of the attack on the potter cottage
wednesday october 31st it was on this
day that voldemort traveled to the town
of godric's hollow where the potter
family lived it was here that voldemort
in an attempt to murder harry ended up
murdering james and lily
he had a very specific goal and that was
to kill harry after disposing of his
parents the time finally came for
voldemort to end harry letting out one
last avada kadavra voldemort had full
intention of killing harry as without
his death there was no way of ensuring
that the prophecy wouldn't come true or
so he thought at last he points his wand
at harry unleashing the killing curse
upon the small child however the curse
was stopped in his tracks for you see a
loving sacrifice that lily had put in
place ensured that harry was protected
this meant that voldemort's killing
curse came firing right back at him what
voldemort essentially did on this day
was turn harry into a horcrux you see
when voldemort tried to kill harry the
curse rebounded which split voldemort's
soul but because voldemort's body was
gone the victim of his own curse he
could no longer encase the soul fragment
to complete the horcrux creation part of
horcrux creation involves an encasing
spell which actually puts the soul
outside of the body into a physical
object because voldemort's soul was left
without any attachment it latched itself
to harry for this reason harry contained
the voldemort soul fragment but was
never possessed by it what this did do
however was form a close connection
between the two of them a piece of his
soul now existed within harry which
meant that the pair shared some thoughts
and abilities harry's ability to speak
parcel tongue for example came from this
bond on a higher level though their
lives were now tied to one another so
what does this mean for harry's
experience on the train well it meant
that harry was living out voldemort's
worst memory of course the pair had a
psychic connection and it's reinforced
again and again throughout the story
that in a lot of ways their minds are
interconnected on this kind of level
after the attack on the train harry is
considerably drained and it's emphasized
throughout the story that he's extra
sensitive to dementors so why would that
be well it's because every time he's
attacked he gets to live out the worst
memories of two individuals his and
voldemorts when harry his screaming on
the train it's from two perspectives his
own and voldemort's it makes perfect
sense that the two would share a worse
memory as well
harry's worst memory being the murder of
his mother and voldemort's worst memory
being the night he was bested unable to
kill the boy who lived as if a
first-hand experience of your mother
dying wasn't enough harry got to relive
it every time he was attacked by
dementors not only that but he also got
to experience all of the anguish and
pain associated with voldemort's worst
memory all at the same time in essence
harry is twice as sensitive to dementors
okay so that answers the questions of
what harry really heard as well as why
harry is so sensitive to the dementor's
kiss however it doesn't answer why
they're so attracted to him constantly
putting himself in harm's way aside they
seem to always be going after him the
dementor's primary form of attack the
dementor's kiss is effectively a means
of sucking out their person's soul a
fate worse than death
so if their main motivation is to suck
out more souls then why should they be
particularly drawn to harry remus lupin
seemed to always express that it was the
horrors of harry's past that drew them
closer to him but i don't agree with
that i've got a different theory like i
mentioned earlier when voldemort
traveled to godric's hollow he
inadvertently made harry a living
horcrux placing a piece of his own soul
inside of him this meant that harry not
only carried one soul with him but a
piece of someone else's as well bearing
this in mind my theory is this the
dementors were attracted to the extra
soul that harry carried with him harry
went about his life in business with an
extra soul strapped to him and i think
this made him a target to dementors a
sort of two for the price of one
to a dementor harry was the ultimate
treat what do you guys think of these
theories leave a comment down below if
you enjoyed the content please like the
video and subscribe to the channel until
next time remember it does not do to
dwell on dreams and forget to live
you